l'accès au pass sanitaire facilité pour
les expatriés français
or yeux c'est le cas aux états unis où
ce qu'ils veulent pourront convertir
leur carte de vaccination locale en qr
codes en perspective d'un voyage en
france
en revanche aucune avancée pour les
expatriés ont reçu un vaccin non
reconnus par l'union européenne elles
sont concernés notamment à les vaccins
russes et les vaccins chinois
on en parle justement avec notre
correspondant à washington tom abonnés à
thomas bonsoir alors comment ça se passe
exactement pour obtenir ce fameux qr
code afin d'être en mesure de se plier
au passé ni terre et donc de pouvoir
rentrer en france cet été pour les
expatriés
c'était un peu un angle mort finalement
de cette mise en place du pass sanitaire
en france quid à des milliers de
français expatriés qui se sont fait
vacciner dans leur pays de résidence et
qui n'ont donc pas ce fameux qrcode
alors une procédure vient d'être mise en
place
ce lundi il faut remplir un formulaire
indiqué un certain nombre de documents
et tout cela il faut l'envoyer à une
adresse mail qui a été créé
géographiquement donc par région une
pour les états unis pour la côte est par
exemple et je peux vous dire que ça
répond à de nombreuses attentes voire
même des inquiétudes de grand nombre
d'expatriés qui sont ici aux états unis
on peut voir notamment sur ces fameux
groupes facebook des expatriés français
qui vivent aux etats-unis beaucoup
d'inquiétude pour ceux qui voulaient se
rendre en france cet été et qui donc ne
pouvait pas être en mesure d'obtenir ce
qrcode alors on verra maintenant comment
cela va se mettre en place concrètement
puisque une fois que ce mail a été
envoyé il faut ensuite attendre la
réponse à des autorités compétentes on
n'a pas encore de délai sur la del sol
sur la livraison de ce fameux qr codes
on peut aussi dire que c'est un petit
peu tardif puisque ce pas sanitaire est
déjà en déjà
il ya déjà ce pas sanitaire en france
pour un certain nombre d'activités et
donc pour ceux qui se sont rendus en
france cet été ça peut déjà être
compliqué pour eux
on rappelle aussi qu'il ya toujours des
restrictions de voyage quand même pour
les français notamment qui vivent aux
états unis puisqu'ils peuvent faire le
voyage en direction de l'union
européenne mais c'est bien plus
compliqué pour faire le voyage inverse
puisque je vous le rappelle est
frontières américaines sont toujours
fermées aux voyages non essentiels en
provenance de l'union européenne et puis
il ya surtout donc un gros bémol
eh bien ce sont les français qui se sont
fait vacciner avec des vaccins qui ne
sont pas homologués par l'union
européenne on pense par exemple aux
vaccins russe ou aux vaccins chinois
alors pour eux il est possible qu'une
autre d'injection soit nécessaire une
injection avec un vaccin homologué par
l'union européenne écouter est ce qu'en
dit le secrétaire d'état chargé du
tourisme jean baptiste lemoyne dans le
jdd pour les vaccins non homologués par
l' agence européenne nous avons demandé
aux experts scientifiques d'évaluer à
quelles conditions il pourrait être
complété par une vaccination avec la rn
messager en france le président de la
république a par ailleurs souhaité que
soit déployé une campagne vaccinale à
destination de nos compatriotes établis
dans des pays où l'accès au vaccin est
encore compliqué il ya évidemment
beaucoup d'inquiétude pour ces français
qui sont concernés ils ne savent pas
encore vraiment s'il ya une
compatibilité entre les vaccins qu'ils
ont déjà reçu et puis cette fameuse
troisième injection qui serait peut-être
nécessaire pour eux et puis quand aux
doses qui pourrait être délivrée est
acheminée en direction des français qui
n'ont pas accès aux vaccins on rappelle
que c'est une promesse qui avait déjà
été faite au mois de mars dernier
puisque le secrétaire d'état chargé du
tourisme expliqué à l'époque que 16% à
des expatriés français dans le monde
n'avaient pas accès au vaccin alors
certains attendent toujours et il y en a
même qui ont vu bénéficier du service
kovacs pour pouvoir se faire injecter
des doses de vaccin si thomas bonnet
pour toutes ces précisions thomas
bonneau notre correspondant à washington